نحن الان في مدينه كهرمان مرعش وهي اكثر
المدن تضررا في البلاد نتيجه الزلزال تعد
مدينه منكوبه كما وصفتها السلطات نقف الان
عند احد المباني المنهاره هذا المبنى من
تسع طوابق الان يقولون بان هناك خمسه
اشخاص عالقين تحت الانقاض في احد مواقف
السيارات احد الاشخاص يقول بانه تلقى
الرساله من
العالقين في
اسفل هذه الانقاض تواصل عمليات
الانقاذ حتى هذه اللحظه مستمره
وتم يتم استخدام الان الكلاب
يعني اجهزه حديثه اجهزه استشعار حديثه
ربما لعل وعسى يتمكنون من الوصول الى
الاشخاص العالقين تحت هذه الانقاض هذا
يعني المشهد الذي تشاهدونه الان هو جزء من
كارثه كبرى ضربت البلاد كما تشاهدون الان
هذا المبنى ايضا قايل الى السقوط قبل قليل
فرق الانقاذ حذرت من هذا المبنى وقالت بان
هناك اصوات تصدر من هذا المبنى وربما يعني
يكون هناك تداعيات سلبيه في حال وجود
اهتزازات ارضيه عموما الوضع في كهرمان
مرعش سيء جدا وعمليات الانقاذ ما زالت
متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه غساله العربيه
كهرمان مرعش